vous êtes notre correspondant à Kiev les
autorités ukrainiennes s'inquiète
notamment du manque d'armes du manque de
munitions aussi à l'approche de cette
date annoncée
la vie de l'OTAN les forces
ukrainiennes utilisent jusqu'à 5000
pièces de artillerie 5000 pièces
munitions pour l'artillerie par jour et
donc il y a clairement un besoin très
urgent de remplir les caisses de
artillerie il y avait eu une annonce du
Pakistan récemment qu'elle fournirait
bien sûr c'est les États-Unis qui vont
payer ce n'est pas par amitié pour
l'Ukraine que le Pakistan le frein
maison en grand en grande quantité des
munitions pour l'artillerie
ukrainien
Ukraine demande à des pays du monde
entier c'est pour cela qu'il y a cette
rencontre aujourd'hui à Bruxelles aussi
réunissant les ministres de Défense des
pays de l'OTAN ce que il faut comprendre
c'est que de la vie de nombreuses
analyses ukrainien en fait c'est
offensif
tellement de temps redouté a déjà
commencé en quelque sorte puisque
d'abord la situation à backgroute c'est
clairement
intensifier maintenant la ville est
fermée pour les civils donc les
humanitaires les médias compris parce
qu'ils disent qu'il y a une risque
augmentée de bataille dans la rue dans
backmouth certains soldats sur place
admettent ouvertement qu'ils pensent que
l'Ukraine va perdre cette ville même si
pour le moment officiellement la
politique est de continuer d'essayer de
défendre backmouth et la ville n'est
même pas complètement entouré pour le
moment je pense que les jours qui
viennent vont nous montrer qu'est-ce que
il qu'elle sera le destin de bac mood
les Ukrainiens renforcent les positions
de défense au delà de Batman et sont
obligés aussi de se défendre de nombreux
autres endroits maintenant sur cette
très longue ligne de front dans le don
de base jusque dans le nord de la région
de loin ce que la ville de SVA trouvé un
peu plus au sud criminal ce sont des
villes contrôlées par les Russes que les
Russes utilisent maintenant pour des
bases pour attaquer vers l'Ouest et le
Sud dans ce qui est de la région de
harki veut la partie nord-est de la
région de harkis les Russes sont
maintenant en position d'essayer de
reprendre du territoire qui avait été
repris par les Ukrainiens en septembre
et puis aussi il y a cette offensive
russe autour de vous blédard au
sud-ouest de donuts qui s'est soldé
peut-être pas soldé puisqu'il continue
de attaquer mais les Russes là ont subi
vraiment de très importantes pertes avec
la perte de nombreuses unités de chars
les Ukrainiens se fait ici donc de voir
que les Russes visiblement en tout cas
autour de vous blédards ont des tactique
peu efficaces ils disent que ils
continuent à résister ces offensives
mais qui subissent une pression
croissante clairement et c'est quelque
part on peut même le dire que c'est pour
certains Ukrainiens c'est même l'espoir
ils pensent que les Russes se
précipitent pour attaquer maintenant
avant que l'Ukraine ne reçoivent les
armes plus sophistiquées que les chars
notamment promis par par ses alliés
occidentales l'espoir je dis ça parce
que peut-être c'est ce que sperme les
Ukrainiens les Russes ont commencé cette
offensive trop tôt alors qu'ils ne sont
pas vraiment prêts et c'est pour cela
que pour le moment les gains affichés
par les Russes se sont vraiment très
petit mais comme je disais on verra dans
les prochains jours clairement s'ils
arrivent à prendre le pac-mouth ce sera
une grande victoire pour la Russie en
tout cas la plus grande victoire depuis
l'été dernier qui le pourront se targuer
donc ils pourront se targuer merci
beaucoup